e devo fare un video con questa cosa che
sembra il maglione di mia nonna
anzi forse è il maglione di mia nonna
non lo so perché e ragazzi fa freddo e
se giocassi maicon questa roba addosso
che la mia maglietta solita rischierei
un infarto è vero che una persona che fa
video soprattutto deve tenere anche al
look perché bisogna dare una bella
presenza ma [ __ ] a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti che sono video sono vari james
e oggi se non su first person marian che
già è parte così c'è dal bianco arrivano
cubi su for mario che ray supermario my
first person mario super mario in prima
persona perfetto si può partire ogni fai
vedere filmati che non mi interessano
prometeo ragazzi cominciamo perché sono
curioso di vedere come come l'alfa io ho
giocato anche mario in 3d un tempo un
tempo
tre vite salve una madonna cioè film si
ma come no fermo dove aspetta e mortacci
ok come cazzo fatto spiegatemi come si
dovrebbe a parte il fatto che sto
giocando col gesso quindi tanta roba io
posso anche posso guardare solo avanti e
girarmi ok capire un casino faccio prima
a guardare in basso a destra seguire il
gioco in basso a destra che guarda non è
un bordello sono ok ok io lo sto capendo
niente di quello che vedo davanti a
questo solo guardando in basso a destra
guarda lo guardo mi si estrae adesso
però guarda è solo con in 3d ragazzi
stavo scalzando la nona la stella se la
stella stella veloce veloce lurido che è
la cosa strana perché io supermario
sempre fatto un po cagare quindi
figurati in 3d con questo e questo e
culo e va beh e vabbè troppa rosi matera
un po avanti ma la che testata che bello
vederle testate in prima persona
credo che alla fine visto gameplay
avrete tutti mal di testa ragazzina cosa
è normale cioè in ormai tranquilli che
cazzo è successo ok ok allora adesso lo
fare tipo che tu mario
alla fine senza cadere bello se fossi
stato in casa mario ci avrei avuto
parecchio nel deretano perfetto a me
fattura mente bene lega c'è per essere
un indie adesso il fatto che carino non
è non è male non è mai così l'interno
del castello
ok ok è vero che i fossi la madonna che
strike è un tipo assurdo giocando il
caso miglia sono sotto effetto di
ecstasy ragazzi tediano dei dialoghi
audio di audiweb di ore di audio vai vai
vai vai vai gara no sono un deficiente
occupo di quei deficienti che ci nasci e
non è che diventi oppure verso ed ove da
dovevi fare partita non dirmi che come
supermario quello vero che parte da zero
dimora parte da zero
li mortacci tua madre è che abbia video
del giorno partirà gah non hanno giocato
tantissimo a supermario quello originale
perché ho avuto il super nintendo per un
periodo limitatissimo quindi non mi
ricordo bene se un certo punto devi tipo
sfondare il tris soffitto si vero ho
stuprato la tastiera ma va bene ma che
estrae plug and strike
[Musica]
ma va ragazzi non ho saltato la faccina
sorella che simula i quadri pacato
spaccatutto dove che cadono ecco io sono
ma sapete cosa vuol dire negare ma
perché
ma perché ma perché non un deficiente ma
non è possibile campioni internettiano
se non sa immaginare in super mario
maker cosa fare dice tirò fuori delle
propaggini assurde non me lo fate fare
ragazzi per l'amor di dio non riesco a
far questo madonna io mi ricordi le
poche volte che ho giocato al super
nintendo cristo nato come un turco piano
piano
no no però perché che proprio dopo prova
di farlo solo parlando di sopra non è
vero non so scherzavo po scherzando dai
lega provo a farlo solo guardando
davanti a che non guardo mi copro non
dategli un post it che copre una parte
destra dello schermo che non voglio
vedere 18 datemi in posti dove dove
francesco sole quando serve non ci stavo
riuscendo normalmente viso voluto
complicare la vita fantastica il bello
raia che voi state vedendo sotto io no
quindi esce quindi potete vedere la
delle mie disfatte prima ancora che io
le faccio questo è suicidato
ok go è bruttissimo non vedo niente zero
tutta la pole è perfetto vai vai vai da
madonna c'è la retromarcia della storia
ragazze manco ci fosse stata una gnocca
a dirmi torna a casa che sono nuda avrei
fatto una retromarcia così io guardo di
sotto mi aspettavi stronzo perfetto
perfetto veloce prima che muoio bravo
bravo sa i capitelli ragazzi col gesto e
macello ma con macello
la donna madonna o raga le medaglie se
riesco a finirlo da così e cioè vogliono
le medaglie che ha a fiumi siamo alla
fine se alla fine me la ricordo taxi mia
come ci arrivo dove vado cosa faccio
perché lo faccio ok ciao ragazzi c'è
quel cazzo di tubo ok c'è il cazzo cioè
6 maledizione se grazie a dio c'è anche
fa ho anche fatto un tempo decente non
si posso credere è bravo bravo bravo
bravo complimenti cioè stato un quarto
reparto un parto certamente in prima
persona il peggio di chetumal cos'è si
può fare qualsiasi può far che figure di
casa parte in prima e bellissima in
faccia mi piaceva da me l'ha testato
godimento ce la posso fare ai ragazzi a
farlo tutto senza morire lo giuro ce la
posso fare adesso adesso lo faccio
immediatamente aspetta che mi preparo
perfetto bravo a cielo fatto farsa farmi
che il credito com'è possibile
[Musica]
ok io non sto guardando e di non sto
vedendo dove sto cadendo questo è il
bello dove questa cosa ok ok adesso
nando è però
madonna sto sudando freddo ragazzi
impossibile ok bella i fatti bravissimo
così
si è incastrato nel muro ragazzi va bè
succeda e zio forza ciò la mira
meno male che non c'era il buco sotto
sennò cazzo perfetto per serio
ce l'ho fatta per lo guardano non
guardato mai di sotto ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi miei ce lo fa è stata
impossibile non è vero che dall'ultima
parte ce l'ho fatta abbastanza bene non
so come non mi faccio domande va bene
così sono contento vorrei ringraziare
tutti il resto emozionatissimo tipo
vorrei esser nato nel 42
uno speciale ringraziamento ad hard nout
che non si sa chi è non probabilmente
non ha fatto un cazzo però il nome dello
quindi lo ringraziamo comunque sia i
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto e cosa
se vi è piaciuto il commento è un mi
piace anche per la felpa che mia nonna
mi starà invidiando è capace di facebook
con il video tra tale cynthia nixon
sensi di skateare ci vediamo al prossimo
vino e ragazzi